[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, I'm Reto Meier.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google,
I'm joined here today by the
director of Android Wear, Dave
Singleton.
Hi, Dave, thank you
for joining us today.
DAVID SINGLETON:
It's a pleasure.
RETO MEIER: So we heard all
about some of the new features
from Android Wear at the
keynote this morning.
I was wondering if
you could tell us,
what are some of the
biggest highlights
from your perspective?
DAVID SINGLETON: Yes, so
today's been really great.
This is our second time
as part of the keynote
at Google I/O. Last
year, obviously,
we announced that
we were working on
Android Wear, and also the
first couple of devices.
So what's been
really great today
is that we really
gave an update.
And we also talked about
some of the new capabilities
of one of our latest updates.
So in terms of the
update we gave,
it's been really great
over the last year
to see the diversity of designs,
and devices, and applications
coming out, which
really gives everyone
who wants to use an Android
Wear watch a lot of choice.
So when we announced last
year, we had two models.
And we now have seven, with
some others in the works.
So it's really cool to have
lots of different shapes
and sizes of watch available.
And also apps-- so
this time last year,
we'd been working with
just a few folks that
had been helping us to make
sure we had the right API's
in place, and that we
were thinking about things
the right way.
Today, we were able
to announce that we've
got over 40,000 apps
specifically designed
for Android Wear.
It's been really great to see
how much innovation developers
have brought to the platform.
I think it's really exciting.
This is kind of the
first time that you
can wear a general-purpose
computer on your wrist.
And by using the same tools
and the same API's that
exist on Android for
phones and tablets,
I think that's pretty
powerful for developers.
At least, that's what I
thought before we launched.
It's pretty powerful that folks
could just kind of imagine
what they want to do with the
completely new form factor,
and hopefully do
it really quickly.
And it's amazing to see
everything that's out there.
So some of what we talked
about in the keynote today
were some of the
apps that we've seen,
that really get us excited
because they take advantage
of a lot of those capabilities.
One that I love is called
Golf Swing Analyzer,
and it uses the accelerometer
and the gyroscope
in your watch to kind
of track your swing.
It's actually really cool.
So you start it.
It says, stand at the ball.
And you start taking a swing.
It realizes
automatically that you've
started to take your swing.
And then it records the whole
accelerometer gyro path.
And then you can play
it back in your phone
to see how well you're doing.
I'm pretty bad at golf.
RETO MEIER: Not for long, right?
DAVID SINGLETON:
Hopefully that's the case.
So that's an example.
But I think maybe something
that folks watching this
might be most
interested in are some
of the new capabilities
of the platform
that we talked
about on stage today
and we're just releasing in
an update that's rolling out.
It's on some devices
already, and it's
rolling out to the
rest of the devices
over the next few weeks.
I think the most exciting
feature is something
we call Always On apps.
So it's been possible
with Android Wear watches
since the beginning to
have an always-on display.
So it was either on by default
or something you could enable,
so that you can always just
glance down and look at time.
And obviously, at
the end of last year,
we opened that up to
developers because we publish
the API's for watch faces.
And there are over 1,500 watch
faces, which is really cool.
Because you can have designs
that help express your style.
But also, if you're
an app developer who
has some really
interesting information
that the user cares about,
you can put that right
on the watch face.
So that's really cool.
But what we have on
ice today is Always
On apps for regular apps.
So you can take an application
like Maps or Citymapper--
things that the user
starts the application,
and you know that
they're still going
to want to refer back to it.
They're still kind of involved
in this ongoing activity
in the real world.
And you can actually
make your app stay
in the foreground, even when
the user drops their wrist
and their device goes back in
to the low-power, ambient mode.
And we showed a bunch
of examples on stage,
but I think that
something that's
going to be really
exciting for developers.
RETO MEIER:
Absolutely, I mean, one
of the things you were
saying this morning
was that you can have
full-blown apps effectively
running on the watch
device itself, which
seems like it's an awesome
opportunity for developers
to create things which are
more than just an extension
of an app that
runs on the phone,
but something which is unique
to this different form factor.
When it comes to sort of
the senses and things that
are on the device, do you think
we've kind of hit a plateau
in terms of the sorts of things
we're going to find on devices?
Or is this something
that you expect
is going to continue to expand?
DAVID SINGLETON:
I definitely don't
think we've hit a plateau.
I think that when we started
thinking about Android Wear
and what we could
do in this space,
we realized that all
technology that we were seeing
in phones and tablets
was on this amazing path
of miniaturization.
And that really, last
year was the first time
that you could put
everything together
into a package that
was small enough
and power-efficient enough
to wear on your body all day
long, and have it continue
to work all day long.
And a lot of the sensors
that are in today's devices
obviously started
in mobile phones,
where they had to be
low-power and small.
But now that there's
this kind of explosion
in wearable devices,
I think we're
going to see a lot more
innovation in the sensors
that you would have here.
And I'm really excited
by some of the technology
that you hear about
in research labs
and in even computer science
and engineering departments
in universities
around the world,
and how those will now start
to become miniaturized, and go
into wearable devices.
It's going to be cool.
RETO MEIER: That's incredible.
I mean, what do you think?
If you're a developer
and you're out there
and you think, this is
kind of interesting,
what do you think
are the biggest
opportunities for someone
who's thinking maybe
I want to move past
the smartphones.
I want to move into
something completely new.
Maybe this wearable
thing is a thing.
What are the biggest
opportunities,
do you think, for [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID SINGLETON:
Right, so I actually
think that the Always
On apps' functionality
that we announced
today is actually
probably one of the biggest
opportunities for developers
in this space to have
come along any time,
really, since we
started the platform.
Because if you think
about it, if you
want to build a
special-purpose wearable
for a specific
application-- for instance,
maybe you want to have a
remote control that figures out
which room of your house you're
in, and controls your lighting
or your TV or whatever.
That's a really great idea.
Wouldn't it be
awesome if you could
build a dedicated
wearable that does that?
And I think a couple years ago,
maybe even just a year ago, you
would have had to hire a design
team, an industrial design
team, an electrical
engineering team,
or somehow find people that
had all of those skills.
And you'd have to probably do
it a Kickstarter, some kind
of crowd funding to get
your initial seed capital,
fund manufacturing, go through
multiple runs of iteration,
just to produce the device so
that you could bring that use
case to life.
But with Always On apps,
you can take advantage
of all of the
sensors, and the fact
that you have a general-purpose
compute platform here,
and have your applications
stay in the foreground
the whole time while the user's
engaged in that activity.
And so for that
example I suggested,
it would be possible to build a
remote-control application that
maybe starts when you tap your
watch as you enter your home,
and then just stays
there all the time.
And so you actually can
turn your watch from a watch
that you could go in and do very
quick interactions on-- which
is still a very core
part of the Android Wear
experience-- into a watch
that, when you want it to,
can become this very special
purpose device for as long
as you need it to be.
And for developers, I think
that means you go from the idea
that these use
cases are important,
or this particular
problem you want to solve
is valuable, to a real,
fully fledged special purpose
device really quickly.
So I'm really
excited about that.
And I'm really excited to see
what people are going to build
on top of these API's.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
It seems like there's
a great opportunity
to weave this wearable computing
stuff into the internet
of things things which
we heard about as well,
with Brillo and Weave.
DAVID SINGLETON:
Right, definitely
very excited about that.
So a lot of what
they've announced
are making some of the
processes of getting
set up with internet of things
devices really seamless.
And I'm excited about how
watches and other kinds of form
factors of wearable are going to
be able to work that over time.
It's definitely going
to be a great area
to see people innovating.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
Thank you so much for
coming and speaking with us.
I feel like I have to ask
you before you leave us.
What Android Wear watch are
you wearing at the moment?
DAVID SINGLETON: So right
now, I'm wearing the Moto 360.
This is the one that I was
wearing on the stage earlier.
I love the Moto 360.
In fact, you see the band here?
This is a nice,
Horween leather band,
but I've actually
had it laser etched
with a little Android of my
own, which was a lot of fun.
The watch that we were doing
the demos on on stage today
is the LG Watch Urbane,
which was the latest
one to come to market.
And it's really great
just to see the diversity
of designs and styles.
RETO MEIER: All right, thank
you very much for your time.
DAVID SINGLETON: Thank you.
It's been great talking.